[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 94 of
the weekly Google Clubhouse phone
podcast I am Francis Campo and I'm here
with my colleague mark Miguel hey Mark
how are you doing I am very well today
how are you doing pretty good very very
excited I'm going to Australia tomorrow
fun I'm going to Vegas tomorrow yeah yes
I think you win I think yeah there's no
cars in Vegas maybe there are you know
what they're probably condos in Vegas
anyway also very excited because we have
two people that were in the bigquery
team before through their coming - tell
us a little bit about bigquery but about
how it's built under the hood yes yeah I
just assumed it was like magic and
unicorns and some other things like that
but apparently there's like real
technology that is yours like cool stuff
there's unicorns there's magic and also
I think it's called Jupiter but that's
the network and then some storage or
something yeah it's a bit so we're mixed
so they're gonna tell us all about it
and then at the end we'll have a
question of the week which is about
Jarvis yeah basically I want to be able
to talk to my phone like Jarvis from
Iron Man but I need to build a bot to do
that yeah
how can I do that yeah I will try to
answer that question as well I am able
to who's gonna be interesting but before
all that we have our cool things of the
week
excellent so I think to this week we are
gonna look primarily at community stuff
which is quite cool I want to bring to
light a little series written by a
person on our team
Lexie he has for the last few weeks been
writing a this week in Google cloud blog
post so if you're looking for possibly
another avenue to get sort of some
weekly news about what's happening in
GCP he's got a really nice little wrap
up medium blog post that goes out once a
week everything from different network
performances Parishad Commandments in
bigquery benchmarks with Google
perception api's kubernetes and Sto all
sorts of other fun stuff so it's well
worth like subscribing and having a good
check out it's really basically like all
the cool things of the week but way more
than that and all in Britain form so if
you don't want to hear
our voices it's a very good option yeah
and speaking of medium as well I will
put a shout-out to another person who
wrote an interesting article that I'll
quite like because you know how much I
like deployment manager hey yeh all I
have is a first name here it just says
grace thank you so much for posting this
grace it's talking about Thai providers
in deployment manager so as you may know
and deployment manager you can deploy
say like a GCE instance or a kubernetes
cluster maybe you want to be able to
automate say a very particular type of
GC instance maybe it has certain
permissions or certain startup scripts
or other things like that you can
actually define your own types so that
you can then reuse those across your
deployment venture scripts so here grace
is showing us how to do that in a nice
step-by-step blog post cool and to
finish we have one more cool thing of
the week which actually comes from the
Tim as a hammer Lee known as tag miser
on the Internet has been a series of
blog posts where she builds a game that
apparently I knew but it didn't know the
name of it it's called battleship for
those that do not speak English that
well or grew up in a different country
Spanish it's called
own data flow da same thing yeah it's to
sink the battleship I like to sink the
boats
whatever but yeah so she explains a
little bit how she built all of the
things of course in Ruby of course yes
aha and I think it's it's pretty cool it
is really cool it's worth noting that
she steps through all the logic but she
has a deployment for App Engine that
it's public with an API so if you want
to interact with the API and play
battleship against it it's sitting there
so you can give it a shot yeah and all
of these is I'm assuming all running on
App Engine so I'm assuming it's App
Engine flexible environment yes I
receive so as well yep awesome well why
don't we go have a chat with our friends
Tino and Jordan and find out all the
magic things that happen underneath the
hood in bigquery sounds good let's do
that cool so I am very happy to welcome
today to the podcast the two gentleman
co-authors of a blog that we really
really enjoyed a blog post by the name
of B query and
the hood so we have today tina Tarasco
hi Tina how are you doing hello how are
you doing great thanks yeah thank you
for coming and we also have Jordan T
Ghani self engineer how are you doing
good thanks thanks for having me
thank you for joining us today we're
gonna be talking a lot about bigquery
under the hood so basically all of the
cool things that make B query possible
but before we get into that topic
whether you tell us a little bit about
yourself and what you do at Google maybe
T know you can start sure up until about
a year ago I was on the bigquery team
working with Jordan and the rest of the
organization just delivering features
and making sure we got the best product
possible now I am the big data lead for
a relatively new organization called
office of the CTO in go club cool we
actually have an episode that either
already came out or will be coming out
soon yes feel not sure exactly about
what octo is very very interesting topic
what about you Jordan tell us a little
bit about yourself sure I was one of the
first engineers on the the bigquery
project several years ago now I wrote a
book about bigquery which is getting a
little bit out of date so hopefully this
can help keep people up-to-date with the
latest changes and now I'm the
engineering lead of the of the bigquery
product awesome cool all right well
before we get stuck into the under the
hoods section we have done several
episodes I think I'm actually counting
about 6 I went back and have a look
where we discussed bigquery itself but
for those who people who may not have
listened or just want a refresher what
like very high level what is bigquery
what's the like the 3 minute sort of
thing so bigquery the quarterly is you
know in very simplistic terms is a
server Louis fully managed whatever
buzzword you want to use high level of
automation service that allows you to
store vast amounts of data or little
amounts of data for analytics and then
perform analytics on on that data in a
sequel format so that's a very very
simple terms but when you actually start
peeling the onion you see that there's a
whole lot of stuff deonda query write
the compute engine of the query the
thing that executes sequel
is actually drummel which is this this
internal service that does ubiquitous at
Google and then we have this fantastic
storage engine it's all tied together
through networking and the the really
the secret glued that nobody ever talks
about is our scheduler in the top of
magic that's that's possible that to
sling resources around from query to
query that's essentially but our
customers really appreciate the
simplicity of the product and and how
easy it is to scale up and down and I
think really the biggest thing again
comes down to the fact that it's ritual
is no ops right it's no hassle you set
them forget the query and you just focus
on things that are important to you yeah
I just add that you know one way of
thinking of it is a a cloud-based you
know no ops data warehouse and it's a
lot simpler simpler to set up and
certainly simpler to scale than other
options cool so you mentioned something
about Dremel just kind of cool because I
know that Dremel is a research paper can
you talk a little bit about how big
query came to be
since Dremel is it the same thing just
like made it available to people outside
of Google or is there any differences in
there it's sort of an interesting story
and we kind of didn't use to talk about
it basically his there were some kind of
internal politics things around it but
essentially a bunch of us in the Seattle
office had gotten pulled off of other
products that we were working on because
the site director wanted us to build a
data marketplace and and so we we all
got together in the in the dining room
with the original tech lead and tried to
figure out how are we gonna build the
state of marketplace and what we
realized was that you wanted more than
like in order to have to be able to sell
large data sets and you know we're
Google we have to deal with large data
that's sort of what we what we do do
best is you wanted more than just sort
of a download link and you also kind of
there's this this concept that when you
have large data sets you need to bring
the compute to the data rather than the
data to the compute so what we decided
was we would build something that would
you to to bring the compute to the data
so you you'd give us your data the data
would sort of sit you know in our cloud
and then you would you would run your
computations and and we we harness the
the internal Dremel engine in order to
to make this happen and sort of you know
six years later you know we haven't
gotten around to the whole data
marketplace thing we might some day but
but it's turned into a quite successful
successful product if I may add to that
I think you know it is it is sure that
the query does sit on top of drama in
terms of the execution part and
scheduling right I think the main
difference is that we can treat Googlers
much worse we can treat external
customers we can we can talk them into
all kinds of crazy weird dog food that
we can't do with customers that that you
know pay us real money and and that's
kind of I think been historically the
way for example the component of drama
that's really undergone really dramatic
change is the actual execution engine
what's in the paper is no longer really
the case these days the new engine
called dermalex has been live for about
two years in production was really dog
food for a long time internally before
the team was comfortable enough to to
kind of thrust around to the rest of the
world and and you know the the average
customer their average user of the query
don't really know when they switched
over to new engine they just kind of ran
a query and all of a sudden that was
five times faster and that's that's
really how they knew they were on the
new stuff instead of the old stuff this
sounds really cool but let's maybe take
a step back from some of the the words
like Dremel and stuff that people don't
know what does it look like so say I've
got I don't know a terabyte or two of
data and I write some sequel how does
the magic happen that turns that sequel
into computation that essentially spans
across multiple computers and does lots
of crazy things can you focus kind of
through that step by step
sure it's a little hard to do without
without diagrams and just just by kind
of describing the the data flow but one
way I think you know of describing the
the Dremel execution engine is there's
there's a query master and there's a
bunch of shards
and the query master gets the gets the
query it parses it figures out a query
plan works with the scheduler schedules
the execution of the different parts of
the query and then schedules a whole
bunch of whole bunch of these shards to
execute that query one of the nice
things about sequel is it's very
parallelizable you know where clauses
and filters can all be completely
parallelized aggregations can be
partially paralyzed and they can be
completely paralyzed if you employ a
shuffle so we have a really fast in
memory shuffle did also gets into the
process the original Dremel the Dremel
paper was sort of a tree shape where
we're kind of the filters would happen
at the lowest level the aggregations
would sort of bubble up the tree but
this didn't really work for complex
queries where you kind of would need to
traverse the tree multiple times and so
now what happens is rather than a static
tree and the query master will kind of
design a multi-level tree so in but
where is in between we used a fast
in-memory shuffle or we in some cases
where we can directly pass the data to
the next to the next stage and this
allows queries to be much more flexible
and allows us to be flexible when how we
allocate resources let me add a little
bit of sugar for my side so you know
kind of like the engineering point and
now maybe the the customer facing point
that I like to think about is imagine
you have this big old those IBM blue
supercomputers needs to be famous in the
eighties in the nineties imagine if you
had terminal access to one of those and
you could just you know rent one of
those for four or five seconds at a time
and just you know pay per second
essentially that's kind of what the
quarter gives you like the query gives
you access to this an incredibly vast
supercomputer that Google manages for
you called trommel and you you push the
button and you say I want to use this
thing for a few seconds at a time that's
pretty awesome cool so now I'm wondering
you saying that there's basically a lot
of computers running these that even
though it looks like there's only one
big computer what is going on in this
basically massively paralyzed query that
is sent all around and I guess
that how there's actually done like that
it that is into the details of the paper
and stuff like that but anchors about
how like how does this actually work
like do you need to have like a cluster
of computers like when kubernetes for
instance you create a cluster and then
you you're ready to start running things
does it were like that or as Tina
mentioned it's a it's a multi-tenant
system so it's it's essentially we've we
host a number of giant computing
clusters and everybody's queries kind of
get time sliced onto onto some of these
some of these clusters and you know we
we strive to give every user 2,000 slots
which basically means 2,000 units of
individually schedulable action that can
they can run in parallel so essentially
2,000 shards per user you might not get
that if you if you query in a very
popular time but um you should nearly
always get get that many that much
execution power and you know and with
that's going to only be a very small
fraction of any of our Dremel trees and
we have a number of Dremel trees that
are around the world mostly in in the US
and in Europe
yeah and I'll answer that as well
George's talking about just the compute
component the quarry drummel unlike any
kind of traditional data warehouse or
data like product whatever you want to
call that the query does have separation
storage and compute which tends to be
popular term these days so quarry is
entirely separate from storage right so
storage is unlimited it's fully managed
it's really really inexpensive but you
can leverage analytic capacity on top of
the storage in a very elastic ways well
also what the court has that's really
unique is we also separate compute from
intermediate State so a lot of times you
know any any typical similar technology
keeps State in the nodes that are
processing themselves
bokura does that but the quarry reserves
the right to keep state and what Jordan
referred to as this separate in-memory
shuffler this allows us to do all kinds
of really interesting things when it
comes to efficiency of performance so
now I'm curious about
you're talking about the compute set of
things and then the story itself things
and for the compute side of things
basically what we're doing is we're
running rather than running one really
big query there is thousands of them
like or I don't know how many but like
many many of those little jobs running
all around that big query tree
how are those managed we had an episode
on Borg is this running on Borg this is
running on kubernetes can you talk about
this yeah so they're running on Borg we
also have our own scheduler to sort of
deal with when you know to reduce patch
queries that you know may be a part of a
query was running on a shard and that
shard dies to recognize that and reduce
patch it elsewhere
yeah the scheduler also kind of makes
you immune from any kind of individual
hardware downtime right the schedule
knows when something's happening and
will try to repair realize the workload
and things of that and Borg is what's
responsible for if a machine dies or
sorry if it's one of those shards dies
it'll restart it and rejoin the the
cluster but one when this fix not want
to make you before long guys is you know
any kind of typical similar technology
when you stand up a cluster
quote-unquote you essentially have a
process that it's really fast
automatically it goes out and puts out
sticky notes in a bunch of hardware it
says this is my hardware right now and
the quarry does that per job very very
quickly right this process that puts
sticky notes and hardware executes in
less than a second at massive scale and
then once the court is done all those
stickers are thrown away right so it's
per job rather than you know per getting
a cluster going type of thing that's
pretty cool cool and something you
definitely alluded to earlier swingbed
so we've been talking about the compute
side and sort of on the storage side is
there anything particularly special
about how bigquery stores the data that
enables it to paralyze in a great way or
able to affect the performance or is it
I mean I'm just just going to assume
it's not just a hard drive sitting on
someone's computer under a desk
somewhere so we use our own proprietary
columnar storage format called capacitor
we looked at a bunch of open
column formats including including park'
which is really
and in the open-source community and
there wasn't anything that would give us
enough control over over how the the
queries are executed for example in some
of the the metadata it's arranged in a
way that that the query engine has to do
very little work in order to to satisfy
a large part of the queries you know the
hash tables that we built were sort of
already pre-built
in in those headers and you know we
followed a lot of research papers and
sort of state-of-the-art ideas that
people had and productionize dit in in
into our storage format so you know each
each column is is stored in a separate
separate chunk of the file and you know
this allows many databases to use column
storage now I think we have a pretty
advanced version of that that builds
that builds on top of the the sort of
the standard column store and it allows
us to a compress better and be read less
data so I lost the pen a question what
does a column store actually give you
like what's the benefit there if you
imagine like if you a record store where
you store a full record and then the the
first record in the next record and then
you try to compress that you know that's
not going to compress very well because
compression works on eliminating
redundancy and the redundancy that you
have across a row is pretty small in
general but usually in a column there's
a lot of redundancy maybe you have
telephone numbers and the prefix is
always the same or maybe you have
countries and there's only like ten
countries that you deal with and so
these tend to these tend to compress to
compress very nicely the other thing you
can do is is especially if you're using
a distributed file system where you're
not worried about like the speed of one
spinning disk is that you can read in a
column store you can read different
columns in parallel because they will
end up under under the hood they will be
stored on on different disk so you get a
faster effective IO throughput by
reading these multiple columns at the
same time cool and I guess that these
also why from the point of view of a
customer B query doesn't charge you for
the columns you do not read it is
because
you actually do not read them so there's
no compute cost associated with it yes
exactly so yeah you save you save on
reading the columns you don't care about
in fact you know that was one of the
original reasons that the Dremel was
created is because there was an engineer
who was doing a lot of you know
mapreduces over these log files and
these log files had actually hundreds of
thousands of columns but he was only
using a couple of those columns and so
he's reading all this extra data and so
he just switched his data to a calendar
format and wrote a little sequel engine
on top of it and you know that's sort of
what what then became Dremel and then
what became bigquery so I have a story
that I heard that I don't know if it's
true or not but I heard that Dremel was
created when those mapreduces that you
were mentioning were actually taking
almost 24 hours to complete to process
24 hours of logs which is a bad place to
be is that true or it's just like a
story that someone told me just to brag
a little bit about it that's actually
true and that the engineer who created
it was you know basically created while
he was waiting for his mapreduces to
finish behind every major innovation
there's a very lazy injury I love the
fact that as well that you're like yeah
so he just put this thing together it's
like a culinary thing and then he put a
secret like it's just like it's fine he
didn't like a couple of afternoons
whatever like an interesting way that
stuff off and can develop at at Google
you know not to you know flog Google to
too heavily but you know is he started
it wasn't it wasn't a big deal it was a
tool that he wrote he wrote himself and
it required a lot of a lot of setup and
you know he hired it how did they hit an
intern and the intern started working on
it and then a couple of the 20% project
people started working on it and now
we've got dozens of engineers and you
know fortune 500 companies relying on it
and they like to say that you know at
Google the the hard problems are easy
and the easy problems are hard so we
built this big massive supercomputer
engine that just churns through data but
for the longest time we had people after
in to approximate count this thing for
example right and that's just kind of
like the nature of the inner this
organic
and you know with because of Google
cloud we actually have to care about
customers so now we have what what the
standard calls for you know and yeah it
did it did lead us to do some things
that in retrospect you know we wouldn't
have done you know Pitino mentioned the
aprox count distinct we're you know
internally folks were like well I'm
doing logs analysis and I don't really
care if there's a million in 17 distinct
users or a million at 19 distinct users
they really all kind of fit into that
same bucket and the algorithm to compute
those is ten thousand times faster to do
it approximately so I'm just going to
use the approximate one and there's you
know there were some syntax things as
well that we were like that made it
easier to process your logs but you know
once we're trying to to get people
who've using sequel other lives to adopt
it they found some frustrations luckily
both of those those things have been
fixed so we've talked so far about
compute we've talked a little bit about
storage about how we store but not where
so I'm curious about where do we store
all of these this is like local disks is
the same Google Cloud Storage we store
it in the basement of 42 oh yeah I've
been there it's nice I know we we start
in in Colossus
so Colossus is our distributed
distributed file system the Google Cloud
Storage also uses Colossus things that
Google tend to be new innovations tend
to be sort of built on top of older
innovations so like the technology stack
tends to be very deep Google Cloud
Storage is built on top of blobstore
which is built on top of the Colossus
which uses BigTable which uses Colossus
and you know bigquery stores data on on
Colossus and you know Colossus takes
care of transparent encryption takes
care of encoding we use an eraser
encoding so that the data is stored
redundantly basically there's some check
sums that are stored out elsewhere so if
there are failures that happen on any
particular disk in any particular chunk
those can be those can be recovered and
it's actually sort of an elaborate kind
of web of check sums that can be used to
recover from lots of lots of failures
and
so our data is actually stored quite
durably within a within a particular
cell and a cell you could think of as a
as a building and then the data is
replicated to multiple locations so we
replicate to a couple of different cells
a couple different buildings within a
region I see so the GC the Google Cloud
terms are zones we replicated a couple
different zones within the within the
region and then we also store an off
region copy of the data to make sure
that in case there's you know a fire or
hurricane or something that that your
data is still durably stored I'll give
them with lime with how the quarry works
you don't know that any of that happens
it just kind of like it's a benefit that
you get and also just just make sure
that I would say if you we don't
replicate your data out of out of the
country that you're storing your data in
so you know if you say you're starting
to you we don't replicate it out of you
you're storing it in the u.s. we don't
replicate it out of the US here's one
more thing I want to say about that
because dramas is big vein that has lots
of compute sitting around and sometimes
you know it's variable capacity demands
on this compute sometimes it's not 100%
actually a lot of times it's not our
HAARP set so we essentially have excess
capacity on the compute side so what was
sometimes the the storage engine does is
it looks at how the data store
physically inside of the query and says
well maybe can it can be better right
maybe this table is driven by 10 million
small files and we can kind of coalesce
that number down to ten thousand or
maybe we can we can do some other
improvements here so and again this is
also happens with our clients knowing
about it you just kind of get
potentially better performance great now
that we've discussed two out of the
three topics 300 to discuss but we're
almost running out of time so I wanted
to just go really quick over to make all
of this happen for real you need a good
network I'm gonna assume could you talk
a little bit about the importance of the
networking things like are you sending a
lot of data around right you know
there's some bits in here that are that
are proprietary that we don't that we
don't usually you
we talked about but you know I think
that one of the real advantages that
Google has is the is the quality of its
status that our networking that means
you can move data you know around
anywhere within within the the cell
extremely quickly and the sort of the
total throughput of that is you know in
the in the pet of it range which is you
know is pretty pretty massive amount
amount of data and it's also what lets
us often compete in performance with
in-memory databases because you know the
kind of performance that we get people
would assume you can't get with with
just regular old spinning discs because
we are able to a parallelize it into so
many of those discs and be our network
is so fast that the overall throughput
is extremely high and it's it's higher
than you know you could likely get
elsewhere awesome well unfortunately we
are running out of time a little bit
well actually quite a lot so we're gonna
have to wrap things up before we go I'll
give you the quick opportunity is there
anything that we happen to have missed
or maybe there's an event or information
that you think people should read
basically if he's last-minute thing you
want to make sure is on the podcast what
couldn't you're there it's you know why
don't you go first yeah I I feel like
that blog post parole was about a year
and a half ago
so it's probably bears actually
expanding on that and talking about
other things that bigquery has like the
data sharing capability and the and they
a memory shuffle a little bit more and
and all the other things but otherwise
yeah thanks for having me one hope
Jordan and you know I'm gonna be
speaking at the the at scale conference
in San Jose at the end at the end of the
month and I'm gonna be talking about the
bigquery storage system and kind of
going into details in the more detail
that we shared before about that how
that works and why we want to have our
own storage system awesome fantastic
well thanks to both of you for joining
today I really appreciate you taking the
time to hang out with us and tell us all
about how bigquery works thank you thank
you thanks again for having such a
fantastic conversation with us at Eno
and Jordan telling us all about all the
things about how bigquery works yeah
really cool yeah I still think it's just
magic in unicorn
yeah there's there was still so much
more to cover but you know we had to
stop it at some point but super
interesting and let's remember that
there was also a blog post that the
world long time ago if you want more
detail and more references the block
will be linked from the show notes
absolutely
cool so question of the week I want like
the sentient robot type thing javis like
Iron Man I want to be able to talk to my
phone and make it do things tell me how
this is possible
ok so I mean if you follow me on Twitter
which by the way should I've been
learning a lot of machine learning
lately and so the way to do this is
first you need to do some signal
processing ok so you need to know like
the basics like Fourier transform and
stuff ok then you're gonna need to
develop probably convolution on your
network ok maybe recurring I'm not sure
ok be able to understand to the speech
recognition uh-huh and then from there
you do the natural language processing
which also uses convolutional neural
networks now eye cream or recurrent
neural networks and convolutional it's
not super hard it's just like basic
calculus ok so that is that is a way and
actually if you want to build by
yourselves you can totally do that
there's a different way which is a
little bit more high-level in that I
recommend which is to simply use like
speech API we have a natural language
processing API yep so those work really
well and you can build a whole thing
from scratch if you want you or even
better you can use something that is
designed specifically for this use case
which is AP ivory yeah and if you either
yeah is a super cool thing because it's
a very simple platform that allows you
to use machine learning even though you
have no clue of how machine learning
works she's amazing
cuz I have no clue I have a little bit
of a clue ok but I'm still realized
really helps and basically what you do
is you define what we call intense and
those intents are matched in between
like the text you're receiving and the
end points on your back end right so at
the end what you develop is basically
just a REST API
mm-hm and you're gonna get like Jason
messages
there you need to respond to those those
for instance if you want to develop like
know like a store you're gonna have
search and buy and stuff like that right
and then you just give examples so those
examples for instance you say I would
like to buy I don't know pixel XL right
now when you say I want to buy a pixel
XL what you're gonna say is pixel Excel
is an entity and I want to buy is the
use case and you just give a bunch of
examples like saying well if instead of
receiving I want to buy is that I would
like to get well it's kind of the same
thing so you just give a bunch of
examples for the strangest thing intent
and that's it it sounds like this would
make a really good episode yeah I really
believe so and I'm actually going to be
speaking about it during the cloud
summit that will happen in Sydney which
I think it's on today these episodes
coming out
yes it's Wednesday so that's gonna be
fun which may be like Tuesday in
Australia or something because you have
can it be the same day but anyway it is
really cool and actually I've been
playing with this a little bit and I
open-source a little framework for those
that would like to do this in go it is
super simple and I built a very
straightforward application to do search
on Google flights directly from your
phone yes and and it works or
unexpectedly it works
yep well well if anyone from the API
wrote AI team is listening and want to
come on the podcast yes we have I have
so many questions to ask them so yeah if
you are in a product manager or an
engineer or whoever an API that a yeah
and would like to be on the podcast
there is a formal invitation right now
yeah
all right princess before we wrap up so
it sounds like you're going away for a
little while yes really
I believe you're traveling soon to go on
a trip yes I'm going in a trip so I will
be going to a bunch of different cloud
summits basically I be a cloud summit in
Sydney which will happen on the on the
13th on the same day there's also cloud
summit in Seattle I will not be the in
that one because you know traveling
across the world takes time so I will
not be in Seattle be in Sydney and then
couple weeks later I'll be a cloud next
Chicago which is on the 27th of
September and then couple weeks later I
will be velocity London on the 17th and
18th of October
then a cloud next Paris on the 19th of
October and then a def is not an amount
on October 20th and after that I don't
know I'll take a break or something
because it's a very tense that's fine
yeah what about you sweet so what is
coming out okay cool so I will be at
Austin game conference on the 25th of
September speaking I will be attending
strange loop when my favorite places in
the world on the 28th of September in
October I really should book some
flights to Australia because I will also
be there I'll be there speaking at their
fest Melbourne as well as at game
connect asia-pacific and probably
pottering around at the very least at
unite moment as well as pax Australia
Wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be four
months and then it's gonna be even worse
yeah brand-new yeah soon it's gonna be
2018 how terrifying is that yeah and if
either one hundred is coming anyway
something will be coming
yeah something interesting cool all
right well franceska thank you once
again for joining me on this wonderful
episode today thank you Mark and thank
you all for listening and we'll see you
all next week
you
you